des coupures d'eau des coupures
d'électricité c'est le quotidien de
Tatiana depuis la libération de rire
seule les Russes frappe tous les jours
la ville et vise les infrastructures
énergétiques difficile aussi d'avoir
internet ce qui rend triste Tatiana elle
est professeur des écoles sans courant
sans connexion elle ne peut pas donner
ses cours en ligne
avec les parents des enfants à qui
j'enseigne
certains ont leur propre entreprise ils
ont proposé de m'aider
et son prêt me fournir un endroit pour
que je puisse travailler
j'ai vraiment envie d'enseigner à
nouveau et je ferai tout pour que ça
arrive le plus vite possible
pendant l'occupation Tatiana comme
beaucoup de ses collègues a refusé
d'enseigner dans les écoles russes elle
donnait des cours aux Ukrainiens
clandestinement
en ligne
et là les leçons que j'enseigne aux
enfants
dans son bureau des poufs pour les
enfants des déguisements traditionnels
des jeux tout ce qu'elle a pu sauver de
son ancienne école est ici son couloir
est également rempli de livres qu'elle
garde précieusement
heureusement que je les ai pris car les
Russes allaient détruire tous les livres
en langue ukrainienne
c'est avec nostalgie que Tatiana revient
près de son ancienne école mais les
souvenirs laissés par les Russes la
hante encore il proposait aux parents de
rerson 10000 roubles soit 150 euros pour
chaque enfant envoyé dans une école
russe beaucoup ont refusé certains ont
accepté
de l'école nous les entendions crier des
choses comme la Russie et notre pays ils
ont commencé à apprendre les chansons
patriotiques russes l'hymne national
russe et tous les symboles nationaux
russes
ça nous mettait vraiment en colère que
des parents envoient leurs enfants dans
des écoles russes
les cours de récréation sont vides à
erson les 171 établissements scolaires
que compte la ville sont fermées
impossibles de les rouvrir trop
dangereux car ergson se trouve juste à
côté de la ligne de front et sans cesse
bombardée par les Russes